let me give you a piece of advice if
you're going to steal steal a lot
sir the police are here please
detective can we talk about this
I'm gonna pay you for your time
stop it's not a cop this is what my son
does he plays these games all that work
for one thousand dollars
if you're gonna steal
steal a lot
what are you doing here just wanted to
say hi I had a good time all right cool
see you around dad
I always assumed my son would inherit
all this he doesn't have the fortitude
he's weak
[Music]
enough
alone of course they like him he's a
billionaire
[Music]
we're celebrating what exactly are we
celebrating millions of dollars
roll up your sleeves trust me
you can't cheat on this man
that's why we never feel sorry for the
mark I really like you I really like you
too
you lied to me we're all human just
doing the best we can you cause your
mother anguish and I will not have it
she wants me gone
how do you think it stands not well
[Music]
what did you tell him I'm gonna take a
billion dollars and aim it in your
direction
foreign
this is real
sure
[Music]
[Music]